karim zéribi du genre non je dis non
parce que d'abord je dis non parce qu'il
faut répondre à la question mais je
trouve qu'elle est pas tout à fait bien
posée faut-il gérer nos flux migratoires
la réponse est à l'évidence oui tout
pays gèrent ces flux migratoires
toute nation est géré ci-dessus
migratoire même les pays du sud par les
pays du maghreb il gère les flux
migratoires avec l'afrique subsaharienne
de ce côté là il n'y a pas de je dirais
de crime a à gérer ces flux migratoires
après c'est comment on traite la
question de l'immigration on la traite
toujours de manière hystérique dans le
pays quand on dit immigration islam
musulmans ça monte dans les dents les
dans les tours on devient fou on est
dans une forme de passion irrationnelle
et on n'arrive plus reposé le débat avec
lucidité responsabilité l'immigration
depuis 15 ans c'est environ entre 200 et
250 mille personnes qui rentrent avec un
titre de séjour sur notre sol et aux
sarabandes 0,34 pour cent de la
population nationale 0,34 pour cent de
la population et des besoins est eric et
marie gillain aussi faire ça n'empêche
pas le débat évidemment il faut le débat
moi je veux dire une chose l'immigration
on en parle toujours comme quelque chose
qui coûte
j'aimerais qu'on en parle dans sa
globalité et une étude qui a été faite
une dizaine d'années qui disait que
l'immigration coûté 68 milliards elle a
remporté son talent à la rapporté 72
on avait un genk 4 milliards pourquoi
parce que dans l'esprit de nos
concitoyens dans la manière on te traite
des bas l'immigré c'est celui qui
viennent profiter de quelques chaussures
c'est celui qui vient profiter des aides
sociales ça congrès je suis désolé de
vous le dire
n'en déplaise à ceux qui sont contre
l'immigration malades avec une forme de
sa vie présente ses mensurations passé
aussi des commerçants
bien sûr des artisans des chefs
d'entreprise ces six cent mille ses 29%
des maîtres de seine en région paca ile
de france et occitanie l'inter si vous
ne voulez plus d'immigration
on aurait 30 % de médecins moins dans
ces territoires
l'immigration c'est aussi une valeur
ajoutée pour le pays alors moi
effectivement je pense qu'on doit avoir
une politique qui s'appuie sur ses deux
jambes
ouverture avec une gestion des flux
migratoires mesure est régulée sur la
base de critères clairs et quand on
rentre pas dans les critères on n'a pas
à obtenir un titre de séjour dans le
pays et quand on est débouté on doit
être reconduit dans son pays
de ce côté là je n'ai aucune ambiguïté
et puis ferme
et sermeter parce qu on a aussi parfois
des politiques qui demandent connus sont
un petit peu faible dans le respect des
règles de notre pays moi je considère
que on doit être moins laxiste qu'on ne
les deux que sur certains aspects je
donne un exemple on avait 1 % des
détenus aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
étrangers pourquoi on a pas de
compétition avec les pays d'origine pour
que les peines s'effectue dans le pays
d'origine
peut-être que cette rigueur cette
fermeté l'a7
je dirai comment dirais-je cette
autorité là on en manque un petit peu
donc il faut savoir dire que
l'immigration ça rapporte au pays et je
les dis je les dis les cotisations
sociales les impôts les immigrés payent
des impôts payent des cotisations
sociales
donc il ya des retraites aujourd'hui qui
sont assurées aussi parce qu'on a des
immigrés qui cotisent de les immigrés ce
n'est pas un fardeau pour la société
et puis aujourd'hui on la voix d'un
certain côté l'immigration nous ne
soyons pas dans ce non pas d'un gisement
la loi africaine on la voit maghribi
donc ça veut dire derrière la religion
mashaie mais l'immigration on l'a
toujours eue elle a toujours vécu des
moments difficiles